and I was in an abusive marriage and my
father yelled at me that I was going to
hell when I walked out I'm sorry I don't
believe in a God that would believe that
[Music]
my wife will not have a pizza unless
there's pineapple on it you can try
anything yeah why not fine it'sa I like
the taste of the cheese the sauce in the
bread that's it it's like it's like
candy those like having candy on the
pizza
I mean I'm I'm nervous because this is a
normal topic that people can usually
talk about but in this climate is very
touchy to even say I believer I don't
believe it's funny I would think that
you would feel safer in the belief
category then I feel in the non belief
category I was raised in a house very
culturally Jewish we talked a lot about
God and religion and many different
religions of the world but I wasn't
raised with any faith with any religious
faith in the house just two years ago I
hated Christians I think I was atheist
bud I voiced all my doubts and
skepticisms and they gave me their
perspective on it that kind of opened me
up and that's why I'm a man of faith
today
if I think if I just choose to believe
that everyone is purely bad or evil then
that's gonna be pretty and then you have
to decide what what the definition of
good it is like according to
Christianity there is no one good no not
one but I don't necessarily believe that
if no one's good born with a sin nature
yeah so that's hard is like my
definition of good made not aligned with
Scripture so it's hard because that's
why I hesitated like I want to believe
everybody's good if that's antithetical
to the Christian belief is that you're
born is sinful it's interesting that the
three of you came who are believers in
that I'm not saying people are innately
good I'm saying well I just learned this
other question as all people are capable
of start with Hitler go from there or
people you know or some people born good
and turn bad I think that's what the
definition of good is subjective that's
why it's like each to each is own for
definition we use kind of hard don't
know what is right or wrong without the
Bible because it's God that makes the
rules without God we have you have no
rules you don't you can't make a
decision on your own whether it's good
or bad what about Hitler he made a
decision right was good and he was wrong
you don't need the Bible to tell you
that well you're born with that God put
that in you Internet conscious as you
believe that's not a belief of the past
I'm an author of two books where I give
the whole history of the Earth from
paleontology geology archaeology
published about for articles on numerous
subjects including politics science
meteoritic dinosaurs
my mother yes I would want people to
think that they have worth in value but
I mean we are all ants on a big boat we
are all very important the design of
those things if a man were to design it
it would cost several million dollars to
make a human if that were possible and
yet he's God has created billions of us
I believe in people I believe we make
our own choices I don't believe that
there is a overriding being controlling
those choices are controlling our
situation you are important I'm so I do
not think that inherently just existing
gives you worth in value I think that
you make choices personal choices every
single day on how you live your life and
how you treat people and how you exist
in the world and those hold on you just
made a definition about what value is
but you still don't believe your
valuable based on your explanation I
said I'm not inherently valuable my to
my being born does not judge based on
your contribution to the world
determines your value don't no please
don't
Oh Kenneth there are many people who
just exist because of instinct or
because do their lives have value I
don't know if they find value in it sure
if they don't maybe not Who am I to
judge whether somebody's life is
inherently valuable
I am a woman of faith in belief I
believe in the supernatural and higher
power and a being that there's no
accident and in the way we were created
yeah I think anytime I have gone through
hardship I have questioned not just what
I believe I question my life I question
my profession I question my relationship
so I think you know if you believe
whether you can't just jump in there if
you like sign me up I agree with
everything let's do that would be for
you but knots not for everybody that is
a believer of any particular religion
people don't question anything but in
your view by it by standing and saying
you know I don't think there's any
higher power you did you ever faced any
doubt well the definition of an atheist
is someone who does not believe it's not
a declaration per se that there is no
God I'm an atheist activist I'm on the
board of atheist United here in Los
Angeles and on the steering committee
for Americans United for separation of
church and state
[Music]
no I've never had a now because I can
see design everywhere and you are not an
atheist you're an agnostic
nope you say mistake no leo tell me what
I am I am an atheist an atheist doesn't
I am an atheist
atheist doesn't do it in the
supernatural period beneath you is an
egg on a stick none of us believe in a
supernatural
it just doesn't believe in tell to you
what an atheist is you're wrong no
atheist you believe in the supernatural
do not tell me do you believe it is you
don't need to make anybody right or
wrong it's just answer the question give
us a nice tuck givers nice to talk do
you believe that this line of
interrogation questioning furthers you
I'm just giving facts Saved by the Bell
I'm feeling frustrated because it's even
a myths of the fellow believers like the
things he says I'm just like yo I'm you
know I don't want what he says to
reflect what my faith is too you know
what I mean I think it's sad that people
are so determined to make other people
wrong and I grew up in a household with
a conservative Jewish mother and a
born-again Christian father and I was in
an abusive marriage and my father yelled
at me that I was going to hell when I
walked out I'm sorry I don't believe in
a God that would believe that it's not
and that is objectively I don't care
that's conversation again we have the
power to choose our response to things
so I choose not to fill her I choose not
to be misunderstood
I think there's safety in being heard
and understood you feel as if the
whatever it is that you want to be
understood about matters it takes energy
and effort to understand someone who's
different I think you know I think we're
kind of as a society becoming lazy sore
like over here different I don't want
and people who are just oh look we all
agree we all have room for food that's
my aspiration on a daily basis is to be
a person we're always learning I used to
think at some point I would like Oh
actualize into oh I've made it I made it
I'm a charity and wisdom do you think
when I'm in college I'll have a figure
yep what are you graduating I'll have
you figure out when I get married I'll
have I figure it out when I have kids I
have it figured out but we're always we
won't reach perfection till we get to
heaven down here is an imperfect world
we can our knowledge is imperfect
our bodies are imperfect our world is
imperfect I mean I'm agreeing with you
but it's all right improvement right
let's stamp us you know what was the
question we all believe that we have
room for you yeah certainly all right
ELISA I acknowledge you for keeping very
very focused and not getting ever heated
but staying focused I appreciate your
honesty and the way you stand up for
what you believe Nancy you have a
presence of self you have a very still
very centered quality to you that is um
very admirable Christine I acknowledge
you for not running out of the room when
you were in a controversial conversation
I acknowledge you for standing your
ground for believing what you believe
and you've got a lot of fight in you
Jeremy I acknowledge you for being
unwaveringly
firm and what you believe and not caring
whether its controversial or difficult
to say what you believe that is the sign
of passion
Peter I think you're growing and I think
you're a wonderful guy and your marriage
is gonna make it grow even more you just
seem like a very comfortable guy who's
willing to learn and grow and that's a
lovely lovely quality exactly Rissa you
have this ability to take stock of
yourself and make decisions like when
you said I choose not to be hurt and so
I'm not hurt it's just it's an amazing
quality and something nice to me sir
yeah
[Music]
you